GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME TO
TODAY'S HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON ACCOUNTABILITY
AND ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW
AS I MENTIONED TO THE TO THE
PANDEMIC WE ARE CONTINUING
TO PRACTICE PHYSICAL DISTANCE
IN HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE
TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WATCH AND PARTICIPATE
IN TODAY'S HEARING IN PERSON
WE ALSO DO YOU REQUIRE THAT
MASKS BE WORN AND PHYSICAL
DISTANCE SEAT BE MAINTAINED
BY ALL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING WHETHER HERE OR AT A
VIDEO CONFERENCING SITE WE WILL
HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS
FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY
IF ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
IS HERE IN THE ROOM AND WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A BILL I
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME AND I WILL ASK
YOU TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
AT AGAIN THE APPROPRIATE
TIME WOULD YOU ASK THE PUBLIC
NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE
LET'S SEE FOR DIAL IN WITNESSES
WE WILL ALSO BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON ABOUT THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR TWO DAYS HEARING
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN YOU
CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON
THE ASSEMBLY ACCOUNTABILITY
AND ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AS WELL
AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN IF YOU
ARE CALLING IN PLEASE DO SO AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE WE HAVE ONLY
A LIMITED NUMBER OF BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA A REMINDER IF
YOU ARE CALLING IN TO PLEASE
ELIMINATE BACKGROUND NOISE
-- WHICH INCLUDES MEETING
YOUR LIVESTREAM BROADCAST
AND SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE
DOWN DISTORTION IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU
CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE
ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE THREE
SIX ZERO ZERO AND MY STAFF
WILL BE THERE TO ASSIST YOU
WILL ALSO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE I NOW LET ME JUST
GO THROUGH A FEW ADDITIONAL
HOUSEKEEPING ANNOUNCEMENTS FOR
THE BILLS BEING TAKEN UP TODAY
WE WILL TAKE NO MORE THAN TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THESE WITNESSES
WILL HAVE TO MANAGE MENT
MINUTES EACH TO PROVIDE THEIR
TESTIMONY AND ALL SUBSEQUENT
WITNESSES SHOULD JUST STATE
THEIR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
THEIR POSITION ON THE BILL
ONLY AT WE DO HAVE ONE BELL ON
OUR PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR
FOR TODAY FILE ITEM TO AB
THREE FORTY THREE AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG FINALLY
I WILL NOTE THAT AB FIVE SIXTY
FOUR OZ FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GONZALES AND AB SEVEN EIGHTY
TWO FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER
I AS WELL AS AB TEN TWENTY
FIVE FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER READ
US WORK PULLED BY THE AUTHORS
FROM TODAY'S HEARING I WE DO
NOT HAVE A QUORUM SO WE ARE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND BEGIN
THIS HEARING AS A SUB COMMITTEE
I BELIEVE OUR FIRST AUTHOR IS
HERE -- MIS READ S.
WHENEVER YOU ARE READY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I WANT TO
BEGIN BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR THOROUGH
EVALUATION OF THIS BILL I'M
EXCITED TO PRESENT AB FORTY
SIX A CRITICAL USE LED MEASURE
SEEKING TO ENSURE THAT STATE
LAWMAKERS HEAR THE VOICES OF
CALIFORNIA'S YOUTH AB FORTY SIX
WILL ESTABLISH THE CALIFORNIA
YOUTH EMPOWERMENT COMMISSION
WHICH WILL BE COMPROMISED
SOLELY OF VIEWS AND FOCUS
ON POLICY ISSUES THAT IMPACT
YOUNG CALIFORNIANS TIME AND
TIME AGAIN YOU HAVE SHOWN US
THAT THEY'RE READY AND EAGER
TO BECOME ACTIVE PARTICIPANTS
OF OUR DEMOCRACY AFTER THE
DEADLY SHOOTING IN FLORIDA
IT WAS YOUNG INDIVIDUALS WHO
TOOK TO THE STREETS TO DEMAND
OUR GOVERNMENT TO TAKE ACTION
ON GUN VIOLENCE YOU HAVE ALSO
BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT ON THE
FIGHT AGAINST CLIMATE CHANGE BY
PRO ACTIVELY LOBBYING ELECTED
OFFICIALS TO ADDRESS THE
CLIMATE CRISIS AND JUST LAST
YEAR WE SAW RECORD SHATTERING
YOUTH VOTER TURNOUT OF OVER
FORTY OF OVER SEVENTY PERCENT
YOUNG CALIFORNIANS ARE ALSO
PARTICIPATING IN OUR DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS SEES AT THE CITY AND
COUNTY LEVEL BY JOINING LOCAL
YOUTH ADVISORY BODIES CURRENTLY
THERE ARE OVER ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY LOCAL USE COMMISSIONS
OPERATING THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE HOWEVER WHILE THERE
ARE MULTIPLE COMMISSIONS
ADVISING THE STATE GOVERNMENT
ON MATTERS PERTAINING TO
SPECIFIC COMMUNITIES THERE IS
NO COMMISSION FOCUSED SOLELY ON
THE NEEDS OF YOU AB FORTY SIX
ADDRESSES THIS LACK OF YOUTH
REPRESENTATION IN STATE POLICY
MAKING BY ESTABLISHING THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH EMPOWERMENT
COMMISSION THIS COMMISSION
WILL CONSIST OF TWENTY FIVE
INDIVIDUALS FROM ACROSS THE
STATE BETWEEN THE AGES OF
FOURTEEN TO TWENTY FIVE TO
ENSURE THE REPRESENTATION
OF TRADITIONALLY UNDERSERVED
YOUTH AT LEAST HALF OF THEM
WILL HAVE EXPERIENCED YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS FOSTER CARE
JUVENILE INCARCERATION OR HAVE
SPECIAL NEEDS THE COMMISSION'S
DUTIES WILL INCLUDE EXAMINING
POLICY HOLDING MEETINGS WITH
YOUTH ADVOCATES AND INVESTING
IN CRITICAL YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED
BY A WIDE COALITION OF SPONSORS
IN REPRESENTATION OF THAT
COALITION I AM PLEASED TO BE
JOINED TODAY BY JASON CHAN
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF STUDENT COUNCILS
AND CALVIN QUICK MEMBER OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO YOUTH COMMISSION
AND LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
OFFICER FOR THE COMMISSION
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
INVEST AT AND MODERATOR I CAN
YOU PLEASE CONNECT US WITH
JASON CHAN THE GOVERNMENT
GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF STUDENT COUNCILS
AFTERNOON CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN
PERFECT GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
BUT INDUSTRY CONTRACT AND
ON THE HIGH SCHOOL SENIOR
FROM LAW HIGH SCHOOL IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND ON THE
GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
SEARCHES TO COUNSEL WE'RE
PROUD SPONSOR OF AB FORTY SIX
FOR THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
-- CALCULATE LATITUDE RUN
CIVIC INSTITUTION FOR DECADES
HAVE BEEN ADVOCATING FOR THE
DIRECT NEED A PUBLIC SCHOOL
STUDENT IN THE K.
TWELVE FIFTEEN CALIFORNIA AS
WE BEGIN TO NAVIGATE TOWARD THE
NEW NORMALCY WE MUST PRIORITIZE
THE NEEDS OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
HAS EXACERBATED DISPARITIES
AMONG OUR YOUTH WHO HAVE
BEEN INCREASINGLY THAT THE
DISCONNECTED FROM THEIR PEERS
FAMILY TEACHERS IN GOVERNMENT
DURING THE FIRST TWELVE WEEKS
OF THE PANDEMIC OVER FORTY FOUR
PERCENT OF YOUNG PEOPLE AGED
SIXTEEN TO TWENTY THREE APPLY
FOR UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE THE
HIGHEST RATE OF ANY AGE GROUP
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE FALLING UNDER
THE RADAR IN CALIFORNIA NEEDS
TO MAKE IT LIBRETTO EFFORTS TO
RE ENGAGE OUR YOUTH ESPECIALLY
OUR MOST MARGINALIZED WE MUST
EMPOWER THEIR VOICES AN APT AB
FORTY SIX VALUED BY CHAMPION
BY DIVERSE COLLUSION IF YOU
COULD CREATE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT COMMISSION
CALIFORNIA'S ONLY STATEWIDE BY
YOUR BODY CONSISTING ENTIRELY
OF USE THE COMMISSION WILL
BE COMPOSED OF TWENTY FIVE
MEMBERS TWENTY ONE POINT BY
THE GOVERNOR TO BY THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON RULES AND TO
BY THE ASSEMBLY SPEAKER THE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES TO
YOUNG PEOPLE MUST REPRESENT
EACH REGION OF CALIFORNIA TO
ENSURE GEOGRAPHICAL DIVERSITY
THESE REGIONS ARE DELINEATED
BY THE -- CALIFORNIA SPENT
THE OFFICE THE COMPOSITION
OF THE COMMISSION AS WELL AS
THE NUMBER OF COMMISSIONERS
IS PURPOSEFULLY DESIGNED
FOR SUCCESS WITH STAGGERED
THREE YEAR TERMS WE ENSURE
THE COMMISSIONERS CAN
DEVELOP A MENTORSHIP CYCLE
MODEL DR -- THE SYSTEM USED
BY THE WASHINGTON STATE
LEGISLATIVE YOU PROVIDE HELPFUL
COMMISSIONERS UNDER SECOND YEAR
CAN MENTOR SUPPORT COOPERATE
CLOSELY WITH COMMISSIONER
REPRESENTING THE SAME REGION
IN THE FIRST YEAR AND THIS
IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT WHEN
CONSIDERING THE STEEP LEARNING
CURVE FOR NEW YOU COMMISSIONERS
FURTHERMORE SEVERAL OTHER
STATE LEVEL COMMISSIONERS ALSO
HAVE TWENTY FIVE MORE MEMBERS
INCLUDING THE COMMISSION ON
AGING BOLLINGER COMMISSIONED
FILM COMMISSION AND EARLY
CHILDHOOD POLITICAL SO OUR
COALITION BELIEVES THAT THE
NUMBER OF MISSIONARIES HIT
UNIQUE NEEDS AND CIRCUMVENT
THE NECESSARY TO BUILDING
A ROBUST AND DEPORTED YOU
MISSION NOW THE CORE ASPECT
OF THE COMMISSION ABOUT AT
LEAST HALF THE POINT HE MUST
HAVE LIVED EXPERIENCE WITH
HOMELESSNESS FOSTER CARE THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM OR DISABILITIES
THE COMMISSION PURPOSEFULLY
UP LESS SUPPORTIVE OF LIVED
EXPERIENCES OF YOU CORPS MOST
DIRECTLY AFFECTED BY STATE
POLICY YEAH DO YOU COMMUNITIES
ARE EXACTLY THE ONES YOU
SELDOM HAVE THE RESOURCES
OR PLATFORMS TO ENGAGE IN
MEANINGFUL ADVOCACY ARE BILL
SOLVES THAT THE IMPACT OF THIS
COMMISSION WILL BE INCREDIBLY
SIGNIFICANT I WILL BE WORKING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS ACCESS COULD
PEOPLE YOUNG PEOPLE WHERE THEY
ARE ALL ACROSS THE STATE IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND THEIR
SCHOOLS -- THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO APPOINT COMMUNITY
YOU CAPACITORS CREATE SPECIFIC
ISSUE YOU'RE ADVISORY BOARD
THAT HOLD THEIR BEATING ALL
ACROSS THE STATE TO PARTNER
WITH OUR EXISTING AS MENTIONED
BEFORE -- HUNDRED THIRTY
LOCAL YOU COMMISSION ANOTHER
YOUTH PROGRAMS AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATIONS MAXIMIZE THEIR
REACH BY ENGAGING COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE AND LISTENING
TO WHAT THEY HAVE TO SAY THE
COMMISSION WILL NOT ONLY LEAD
CALIFORNIA TO MAKE EDUCATED
DECISIONS ON CRUCIAL YOUTH
RELATED POLICIES BUT ALSO
DIRECTLY AND MEANINGFULLY
ENGAGE MANY YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE
A QUICK WHICH IS SO CRUCIAL TO
BUILDING A HEALTHY AND THRIVING
DEMOCRACY OVER THE PAST TWO
YEARS YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
MARCHING IN THE STREETS AND
MORE RECENTLY ORGANIZED IN
VIRTUALLY BUT THAT'S BECAUSE
THERE ARE SO MANY ISSUES THAT
AFFECT YOUNG PEOPLE IN THEIR
COMMUNITY FOR ENERGIZED WITH
PASSIONATE WE WANT TO MAKE
A CHANGE WE'RE WE HAVE YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE THE FUTURE AND
ABOUT TIME TO START POWERING
IT -- I'D LIKE TO THANK A
COLUSA RIVAS FOR SHAPING
CULTURE POWERFUL BILL THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I.
ABOUT THANK YOU COMMENTS THAT
MODERATOR IT'S NOT CONNECTS
WHAT'S THE PROBLEM RIGHT RENDON
GOOD AFTERNOON CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU YES THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CALVIN
QUICK REPRESENTING THE SAN
FRANCISCO YOUTH COMMISSION
PROUD COULD SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL TO CREATE A STATEWIDE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH EMPOWERMENT
COMMISSION TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU FORCES ARE REPRESENTED
IN STATE GOVERNMENT THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TODAY AND I'LL BE TALKING
A BIT ABOUT THE PURPOSE AND
WORK UP TO SAN FRANCISCO HUGE
COMMISSION IN THE CONTEXT OF
THIS BILL AB FORTY SIX D.
SAN FRANCISCO YOU COMMISSION
WHICH I'VE FOUGHT ON FOR
THE PAST THREE YEARS WAS
ESTABLISHED BY SAN FRANCISCO
VOTERS BACK IN NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE AT THE BODY OF THE
SEVENTEEN YOUTH BETWEEN THE
AGES OF TWELVE AND TWENTY THREE
WITH THE ROLE OF ADVISING OUR
LOCAL BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
MAYOR ON POLICIES THAT AFFECT
YOUNG PEOPLE FOR INSTANCE
ALL PROPOSED LOCAL BUDGETS
STATION THAT WOULD IMPACT
SAN FRANCISCO YOUTH MUST BE
REFERRED TO US FOR COMMENT AND
RECOMMENDATION BEFORE A FINAL
DECISION CAN BE MADE AND WE
ALSO HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO MAKE
INDEPENDENT RECOMMENDATIONS
ON BUDGET AND POLICY MATTERS
TO DECISION MAKERS MAINLY
THROUGH RESOLUTIONS AND ARE
ENABLE BUDGET AND POLICY
PRIORITIES REPORT SOME PAST
SUCCESSFUL YOUTH LED CAMPAIGNS
INITIATED OR SUPPORTED BY THE
SAN FRANCISCO YOUTH COMMISSION
HAVE INCLUDED PASSING A
PROGRAM TO MAKE LOCAL TRANSIT
FREE FOR YOU ADVOCATING FOR
THE CLOSER SAN FRANCISCO IS
UNDER UTILIZED JUVENILE HALL
EXPANDING USE MIRANDA RIGHTS
PROTECTIONS AND OPENING A USE
HOMELESSNESS APPLICATION CENTER
AND THAT'S JUST IN THE LAST
DECADE SOME OF THE HIGHLIGHTS
I DO FOR PREVENTATIVES OF OUR
COMMUNITIES WE FREQUENTLY HOST
OR CO HOST COMMUNITY EVENTS
AND TOWN HALLS ON ISSUES
FROM TRANSPORTATION EQUITY
TO YOUTH CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
AND POLICE ACCOUNTABILITY
AND WE MAINTAIN CLOSE WORKING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND LOCAL
DEPARTMENT STOCKS AB FORTY SIX
WOULD BUILD ON THE SUCCESSES OF
LOCAL USE COMMISSIONS LIKE THIS
SINCE SAN FRANCISCO OAKLAND AND
MANY OTHER STATE CITIES AROUND
THE STATE BY ESTABLISHING A
STATEWIDE COMMISSION COMPOSED
ENTIRELY ACCUSE ADVOCATE
AND ACTIVISTS WHOSE CENTRAL
PURPOSE IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU FORCES AND THE EXPERIENCES
ARE ACTIVELY INFORMING POLICY
DECISIONS MADE BY THE STATE
AROUND THOSE ISSUES THAT
DIRECTLY AFFECT US AND OUR
COMMUNITIES JUST WANT TO AGAIN
THANK AND APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BE OFFICE FOR CARRYING
THIS BILL AND BE RESPECTFULLY
URGE AND I KEPT THINKING
THANK I NOW LET'S SEE THAT
IS THERE ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT -- WITH
THE MODERATOR NOW PLEASE
OPEN UP THE MAIN LINE FOR
ADDITIONAL FOR TESTING
AND IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
OF AB FORTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU'RE
IN SUPPORT OF AB FORTY SIX
AND AT THIS TIME IT DOES
LOOK LIKE WE'VE ABOUT
FOURTEEN IN OUR QUEUE
GREAT SO OUR MODERATOR IF YOU
CAN YOU CAN PLEASE GO AHEAD
AND I OPEN THEIR LINE SO THAT
THEY CAN MAKE THEIR COMMENTS
ABSOLUTELY WILL START WITH
NUMBER THIRTY ONE OF THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MECOLE MORTAL MEN ON BEHALF
OF THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP
IN SUPPORT OF AB FORTY SIX
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
NUMBER THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
FOR A SECOND SALAS NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
NEXT WE'LL MOVE TO NUMBER FORTY
TWO FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
NUMBER FORTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
I'LL MOVE ON TO NUMBER NINETEEN
-- NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO KELLY HARDY WITH
CHILDREN NOW INSTRUCT
THE COURT THANK YOU
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER FORTY SIX
OF FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
NUMBER FORTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
MOVED TO NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI AM I A BROWN ON BEHALF
OF THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF AB FORTY SIX
TO BE NUMBER THIRTY SIX
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES I CAN HEAR YOU OKAY ERIC
MOST METROPOLITAN LINCOLN
THE ALLIANCE OF WHITE MEN OF
COLOR WE ARE COSPONSORED AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FOUR
SIX THANKS FOR YOUR TIME
NEXT WE NUMBER FORTY EIGHT
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DENTAL
USE ON BEHALF OF PREVENTION
INSTITUTE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB FORTY SIX THANK YOU
ANNEXING THE NUMBER
THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO THIS IS DANIEL OF
OCTOBER GENERATION UP TO HELP
THE STUDENTS STRONG SUPPORT
NEXT TO BE NUMBER THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M SHARING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MANY SURELY YOU'VE BEEN ON THE
JUSTICE DIRECTORATE MY PAST
NATIONAL BASED NONPROFIT IN
SAN FRANCISCO FOUR COMPANIONS
FINANCIAL ACCESS AND ECONOMIC
INCLUSION IN STRONG SUPPORT
FOR A BI FORTY SIX THANK YOU
NEXT TO BE NUMBER TWENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
BRIANNA WILLIS I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR FREEDOM CENTER AND
I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB FORTY SIX
NEXT IS GOING TO BE NUMBER
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
NUMBER FORTY YOUR LINES OPEN
THE NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD ALL GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JORDAN
THOUGHT THAT AND HERE ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION
WHERE YOU ORGANIZATION -- THAT
-- EMPOWER EACH OTHER AND THE
COMMUNITIES TO TRANSFORM THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM REFLECTED
OFF THE PRACTICE CHANGE
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT AND
PROUD SPONSORS AB FORTY SIX
THANKS FOR THE NUMBER
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD HI
MY NAME IS AINSLEY LANG -- I
AM A STUDENT AT LINCOLN HIGH
SCHOOL IN LINCOLN UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN STOCKTON AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB FORTY SIX
WELL NOW GO TO NUMBER FIFTY
TWO FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON CAN REST
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUTH IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND ONE
OF THAT COULD SPONSOR THE
AB FORTY SIX THANK YOU
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB FORTY
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
WE'LL GO TO LINE FORTY SIX
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
CAN YOU GIVE ME
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU HI MY
NAME IS JACOB FRANCISCO I'M
A STUDENT BOARD MEMBER AND
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FORTY SIX
AND AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MADAM CHAIR THANK
YOU IS THERE ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FIRE REMOTE
VIDEO STATION AT THIS TIME
SCENE NINE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT C.
NINE I WITH THE MODERATOR
NOW OPEN THE MAIN LINE FOR
ANY OPPOSITION TESTIMONY
ANALYZE YOUR MANAGER IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FORTY SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AGAIN
PROPOSITION PRESS ONE ZERO
CAN ANY OPPOSITION FOR AB
FORTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
YES AT THIS TIME THERE ARE
NONE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MR MADAM CHAIR HI
IS THERE ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION REMOTE
VIDEO NO SEEN NONE ANYONE IN
THE ROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION SCENE NINE QUESTION
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
CNN ASSEMBLY MEMBER REQUESTS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR THE DISCUSSION
ON THIS IMPORTANT PROPOSAL I
BELIEVE OUR DEMOCRACY IS BETTER
SERVED WHEN YOUTH ARE GIVEN
AN OPPORTUNITY TO CONTRIBUTE
THEIR UNIQUE PERSPECTIVES THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE THANK YOU WE WILL ADD
TAKE UP THAT BILL ONCE WE'RE
ABLE TO ESTABLISH APARTMENT
MOVE FROM A SUB COMMITTEE
BUT THANK YOU FOR INTRODUCING
THIS MEASURE THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT I WANT TO ADD
AB SEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
A GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND COLLEAGUES PROUD TO
PRESENT DAY A. B.
SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT THIS IS A
BIPARTISAN BILL THAT DEALS
WITH THE STATE INSTITUTIONS
AND THE PROCUREMENT OF
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS
AB SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT WOOD
DIRECTOR STATE INSTITUTIONS AND
SCHOOLS TO PURCHASE CALIFORNIA
GROWN FOOD WHEN AVAILABLE AND
WERE NOT AVAILABLE THEY WOULD
BE REQUIRED TO GIVE PREFERENCE
TO US GROWN FOOD OVER FOREIGN
FOOD CURRENT LAW DIRECTS OUR
INSTITUTION INSTITUTIONS TO
GIVE PREFERENCE FOR FOOD GROWN
IN THE STATE WHEN THE PRICE
OF CALIFORNIA PRODUCE DOES NOT
EXCEED THE OTHER STATE PROGRAMS
BY MORE THAN FIVE PERCENT
HOWEVER CURRENT LAW EXEMPTS OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND UNIVERSITIES
WHICH ARE AMONG THE LARGEST
PUBLIC INSTITUTIONAL PURCHASERS
OF AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS WHILE
FEDERAL LONG TO THE BUY AMERICA
PROVISION THAT REQUIRES SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO PURCHASE DOMESTIC
COMMODITIES AND PRODUCTS FOR
SCHOOL MEALS LOOPHOLES IN THE
LAW ALLOWS SCHOOLS TO PURCHASE
CHEAPER FOREIGN PRODUCTS
INSTEAD OF CALIFORNIA GROWN
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS FOR
EXAMPLE THE SACRAMENTO BEE
STORY IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
FOUND THAT THE SACRAMENTO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
PURCHASE CANNED PEACHES AND
MIXED FRUIT FROM CHINA IN
VIOLATION OF BUY AMERICA
POLICIES EVEN THOUGH NEARLY ALL
US CANNED PEACHES AND PLASTIC
PACKAGE PEACHES ARE GROWN HERE
IN CALIFORNIA FURTHERMORE IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
STATE AUDITOR ISSUED A REPORT
THAT FOUND THAT NONE OF THE
SIX SCHOOL DISTRICTS REVIEW
REVIEWED HAVE ADEQUATE POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES TO IMPLEMENT
BUY AMERICA LAWS AND THEY HAD
TO PURCHASE FOREIGN SOURCE
FOOD ITEMS BUT DID NOT HAVE
ADEQUATE DOCUMENTATION TO
JUSTIFY THOSE PURCHASES DESPITE
OUR STATE AGRICULTURAL STRENGTH
PRODUCERS FACE COMPETITION
FROM NON DOMESTIC PRODUCERS IN
CHINA MEXICO ANOTHER NATIONS
THAT DO NOT HAVE THE SAME
LABOR ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
AND QUALITY CONTROL AS WE DO
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE EXTREMELY
PROUD OF -- IN ORDER TO KEEP
CALIFORNIANS SAFE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTION SPEND NEARLY THREE
HUNDRED MILLION ANNUALLY ON
FOOD PURCHASING AND CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS ARE ESTIMATED TO SPEND
BETWEEN FIVE HUNDRED AND NEARLY
SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION ANNUALLY
ON DIRECT FOOD PURCHASES THIS
IS NEARLY ONE BILLION THAT
THE STATE COULD BE DIRECTED
TOWARD SUPPORTING CALIFORNIA
FARMERS I'M NOT FARMWORKERS
BY PURCHASING CALIFORNIA
GROWN FOOD CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY BENEFITS WHEN STATE
INSTITUTIONS DIRECT PURCHASING
POWER TORQUE CALIFORNIA GROWN
PRODUCTS AND FARMERS REINVEST
THIS MONEY BACK INTO THEIR
ESSENTIAL WORKFORCE THE ECONOMY
AND THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITIES WE
SHOULD BE GIVING OUR FARMERS
THE BENEFIT OF DOUBT AS I THINK
WE ALL WOULD AGREE CALIFORNIA
STATE AGRICULTURE PRODUCTS
ARE THE BEST IN THE NATION
AND PERHAPS EVEN IN THE WORLD
COMMITTING TO BUY CALIFORNIA
GROWN IN A PROGRAM LIKE
THIS IS FUNDAMENTAL THE BILL
ENJOYS THE SUPPORT OF EVERY
COUNTY FARM BUREAU AND EVERY
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE FROM THE
INLAND EMPIRE WHICH IS WHERE
THE BILL WAS THOUGHT OF --
WITH ME WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES
THEY'VE BEEN TOLD TO KEEP IT
SHORT AND SWEET CELESTA ALONSO
WHICH IS A KENTUCKY FARMER AND
RICH HUDGENS CALIFORNIA CAN
TEACH ASSOCIATION GREAT AND
THAT MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
CONNECT US WITH US LAST ALONSO
SELECT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
OKAY A GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE -- MY NAME
IS THE WHAT THE LONG THOUGH
AND I'M THE GENERAL MANAGER
FOR MY FAMILY FARM JUNIOR
AND THE ENTERPRISES LLC IN
COACHELLA MY GRANDPA BEGAN
FIRING THE COACHELLA VALLEY
IN THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES
ALONG WITH MY DAD JUNIOR MY
TWIN BROTHER AND I LOVE TO
COLLEGE AND RETURNED TO WORK
ON THE FAMILY FARM THAT MIGHT
TRANSLATE THAT ONTO A THIRD
HOW THE SUN SOME OF THE FOURTH
UNFORTUNATELY WE DO NOT KNOW
OF MINE BUT I FEEL A LITTLE
THE WE WILL BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
THE FAMILY BUSINESS STUDENTS
ARE GRANULATION CALIFORNIA
HAS PUT AN AGRICULTURE ALONG
WITH THE REGULATIONS WITH HER
THE COST OF HEALTHCARE FOR
EMPLOYEES WORKERS COMPENSATION
AND THERE ARE THE MINIMUM WAGE
ARE GROWING COST OF BECOMING
EXPONENTIALLY HIGHER IN THE
LAST YEAR AT A PANDEMIC WE
ARE STRUGGLING WE NEED TO
LOOK FOR CALIFORNIA GROWERS
BY MANDATING THAT ALL STATE
INSTITUTIONS BY TELEPHONE
NUMBERS BEFORE IMPORTING
PRODUCE FROM OTHER STATES OR
COUNTRIES MY FAMILY WANTS TO
CONTINUE GROWING AND BUCKLEY
PROTECTIVE IN OREGON THAT YOU
NOT HAVE TO CONTEND WITH THE
STATE REGULATION CALIFORNIA
HAS PUT ON OUR CULTURE
CALIFORNIA HAS THE STRICTEST
REGULATIONS IN THE COUNTRY
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
FOOD SAFETY IT IS NOT THAT
WE OPPOSE THESE REGULATIONS
WE ARE PROUD THAT OUR STATE
IS A LEADER IN PROTECTING OUR
ENVIRONMENT OUR WORKERS AND
OUR CONSUMERS HOWEVER BEING A
LEADER HOW THE NEXT ECONOMIC
COST TO PRODUCE ALL WE ARE
ASKING AS FAR AS DISCOURAGING
BIRTH SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA
GROWERS ARE GOING TO THINK WE
ARE PROVIDING LIVING WAGES I
HAVE THE HONOR OF BEING PART OF
ORGANIZATIONS OF THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU AND THE TOP WORK
OUR CULTURE LEADERSHIP PROGRAM
THIRTY PROGRAMS I HAVE HAD THE
CHANCE TO VISIT OTHER STATES
SUCH AS TEXAS OF GEORGIA AND
WENT INTO OUR CULTURE RECEIVE
THE BILL STATE AND THEY'RE
AYE FARMERS ARE HEROES FARMERS
ARE MAKING THEIR TABLES AND
THE GOVERNMENT TURNED HEALTH
PARTNERS FOR EXAMPLE IN GEORGIA
FARMERS DO NOT PAY TAXES ON
THEIR EQUIPMENT I'M NOT ASKING
FOR CALIFORNIA TO SEE OTHERS
HEROES THE TECHNOLOGY THAT WE
ARE TRYING TO DO OUR JOB WHICH
IS TO BE IN OUR STATE AND WE
NEED HELP BY BUYING CALIFORNIA
FIRST WE SECURE A FUTURE THE
NEXT GROWING SEASON LET'S ALL
KEEP OUR CULTURE ALIVE IN OUR
BEAUTIFUL STATE BUT WILL ALSO
KEEP OUR EMPLOYEES EMPLOYED
AND HOPEFULLY LITTLE LOUISE
WILL BE ABLE TO HAVE THE
THING OPPORTUNITY MY GRANDPA
MY DAD AND MYSELF HAVE HAD
TO GIVE THANK YOU MS ALONSO
AND I BEFORE WE MOVE TO OUR
NEXT WITNESS WE'RE GOING TO
GO AHEAD AND ESTABLISH QUORUM
AT SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL PETRIE-NORRIS HERE
PETRIE-NORRIS PRESENT PATTERSON
BURKE BURKE PRESIDENT GRAY
LACKEY MEDINA HERE MEDINA
PRESENT RODRIGUEZ -- RODRIGUEZ
PRESENT WE HAVE ACCORDING
TWENTY FOUR A QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED I WILL GO AHEAD
AND NOW IN HERE FROM OUR
NEXT WITNESS ON THE LINE --
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE I
CONNECT US WITH RICH HUTCHINS
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME'S
RICH HUTCHINSON PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA CANNING
PEACH ASSOCIATION FOR A GROWER
OWNED COOPERATIVE REPRESENTING
NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED PEACH
FARMERS -- IN CALIFORNIA --
PRODUCE SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT
OF THE STATE'S CROP AS A
PRACTICAL MATTER CALIFORNIA
PROVIDES VIRTUALLY ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT OF THE NATION'S
DOMESTIC AND PEACH APPLY
WE'VE EXPERIENCED A SIGNIFICANT
DECLINE IN THE CALIFORNIA
PEACH INDUSTRY -- DURING
THE PAST THIRTY YEARS DUE
PRIMARILY TO SUBSIDIZED
IMPORTS ERELI ENTERING
THIS COUNTRY FROM CHINA
WE'RE EXPRESSING OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR LEGISLATION
ENSURING THAT TAXPAYER
DOLLARS SPENT FOR FOOD
PURCHASES BENEFIT CALIFORNIA
GROWERS PROTECT UNION JOBS
IN PROCESSING PLANTS AND
PACKING HOUSES THROUGHOUT
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND THE
COACHELLA VALLEY SPEAKING JUST
ABOUT THE PRETENDING INDUSTRY
THERE ARE OVER EIGHT THOUSAND
TEAMSTER EMPLOYEES WORKING
IN PROCESSING FACILITIES
THROUGHOUT THE CENTRAL VALLEY
THREE STATUS OF WOMEN GARCIA
MADE REFERENCE TO THE HISTORY
OF CANNED PEACHES WITH THIS
ISSUE WELL I RECOGNIZE THAT
MOST OF YOU DON'T HAVE EACH
ORCHARDS IN YOUR DISTRICTS
IT IS VIRTUALLY CERTAIN ANY
SCHOOL IN YOUR DISTRICT WHO
IS SERVING APPLE JUICE THE
STUDENTS IS SERVING A PRODUCT
MADE FROM CHINESE APPLE JUICE
CONCENTRATE EVERY SINGLE THAT
IN FACT IT WOULD ALSO AVOID
UNDERMINING EXISTING EFFORTS IN
THIS STATE TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS AS A RESULT OF
IMPORTING FOOD PRODUCTS FROM
NATIONS WITH LESS STRINGENT
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS
IT WOULD ALSO BETTER ALIGN
CALIFORNIANS WHO PROCUREMENT
POLICY WILL BE ENHANCED BY
AMERICAN DIRECT IS OUTLINED
IN PRESIDENT BIDEN'S JANUARY
TWENTY FIFTH EXECUTIVE ORDERS
SIMPLY PUT WE SHOULD NOT BE
CONTRACTING TO SPEND TAXPAYER
MONEY TO PURCHASE FOREIGN
SOURCED FOOD IN CALIFORNIA
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
TOGETHER TO CRAFT WORKABLE
LEGISLATION ENSURING THAT
TAXPAYER DOLLARS ARE SPENT ON
AMERICAN GROWN FOOD PRODUCTS
WHICH WILL SUPPORT OUR FARMERS
AND PROTECT UNION JOBS IN
PROCESSING FACILITIES BY THE
WAY MANY OF WHICH ARE LOCATED
IN DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE IT WOULD
ALSO HAVE THE BENEFIT OF
PROVIDING HER STUDENTS WITH
THE SAFEST FOOD AVAILABLE WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
ON EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT
THANK YOU MISTER HUDGENS
BUT THE MODERATOR NOW PLEASE
OPEN UP THE MAIN LINE FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTING TESTIMONY
AND LATELY -- AND IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOUR SUPPORT
AND AT THIS TIME IT
DOES LOOK LIKE WE HAVE
ABOUT TEN IN THE QUEUE
HELLO START WITH NUMBER
FORTY ONE OF FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
THAT IS WHERE MEMBERS I
APOLOGIZE THE NEED OF A NEW
WIENER AND MY NAME IN THERE
UNLOCKED I REMEMBER THAT
HE DID YOU LABOR MANAGEMENT
COOPERATION AND THAT IS A
LONG NAME THE PARTNERSHIP
YOU HAVE GIVEN THAT
ALLEGE THAT'S OKAY
PERHAPS RIGHT BACK AGAIN
IS THAT BETTER THAT IS BETTER
MONICA I AM A BIT BETWEEN -- I
REPRESENT DAY CANNERY INDUSTRY
LABOR MANAGEMENT COOPERATION
COMMITTEE YOUR SHIP AT UNION
CANNERY WORKERS AND PRODUCERS
AND WE WERE ORIGINALLY THE
SUPPORTERS AB AT TEN TWENTY
FIVE -- BY MR VIDA WE KNOW THAT
BILL HAS BEEN HELD BECAUSE IT
WAS SIMILAR TO THAT MR GARCIA'S
BELL WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH MR GARCIA TO FIGURE
OUT A BILL THAT IS WORKABLE
AND THAT WILL TO SUPPORT AG
PRODUCERS AS WELL AS WORKERS
WHO DEPEND ON THE JOBS IN THAT
INDUSTRY THANK YOU THANK YOU
THE NEXT WILL BE NUMBER
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR TAYLOR OCEAN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU IN STRONG SUPPORT
WELL NOW MOVES TO NUMBER
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
-- GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
I'M ANTHONY BIANCO COURT CO
OWNER THIRD GENERATION FARMER
I'M HAPPY VINEYARDS WITH
OPERATIONS IN BOTH COACHELLA
AND CENTRAL CENTRAL VALLEY I AM
ALSO A FARMER WHO CARES DEEPLY
ABOUT CALIFORNIA FARMWORKERS
AND ITS ENVIRONMENT AB SEVEN
SEVEN EIGHT IS A CALIFORNIA
FARM WORKER BILL A CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL BILL AND A
CALIFORNIA FORMER BILLS I'M
SORRY TO BE THE FIRST TIME IN
CALIFORNIA NOT IN THE SECTION
WHERE WE CAN ONLY TAKE WORK
WE'RE JUST TAKING YOUR AT YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
OUR NEXT MOVE TO NUMBER
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
CHRIS CON REPRESENTING
THE COACHELLA VALLEY
WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT
I'M NOT GONNA NUMBER FIFTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD YES
YOU SHOULD NOW PURSUE WITH
GROWING COACHELLA VALLEY
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT THANK YOU
NEXT IS NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD MY NAME IS
GEORGE TUTOR TUTOR RANCH IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN
SEVEN EIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NOW GO TO NUMBER FIFTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
A FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
GOOD AFTERNOON ADELINE EVELYN
THIS CALIFORNIA PROMOTER
FOUNDATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
WE WILL NOW GO TO LINE
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR ADAM
BORCHARD BUT THE CALIFORNIA
FRESH FRUIT ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT
NEXUS NUMBER FIFTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
AFTERNOON -- BLAME CARRYING
VICE PRESIDENT DOES REFRESH IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SEVEN SEVEN
NEXT WE NUMBER TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM TURN
MEMBERS TRICIA GERINGER WITH
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL CALIFORNIA
WITH A SUPPORT IT AMENDED
POSITION WHILE WE CONTINUE
CONVERSATION WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA APPRECIATE
HIS LEADERSHIP AND OUTREACH
TO LOOK FORWARD TO ONGOING
COLLABORATION THANK YOU
NEXUS NUMBER TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI DAVE RUN STAND TO
NEARLY ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY
FARMERS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN
SEVEN EIGHT PRESS ONE ZERO
HOW WE DO HAVE ONE MORE QUEUING
UP IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT
WE'LL GO TO NUMBER FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
MARKET MARKET SURE RICK
OVER SHEA THE CELLO VALLEY
FEBRUARY MEMBER STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT
AT THIS TIME THERE ARE
NO FURTHER IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY -- VIA
REMOTE VIDEO STATION C.
NINE IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT SAM NUNN A MODERATOR
CAN YOU OPEN THEM MAINLINE NOW
FOR ANY OPPOSITION TESTIMONY
BARRY CHIN OPPOSITION
OF AB SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO I
GOT ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION
ONCE AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NONE IN
THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE MADAM
CHAIR IS THERE ANYONE WISHING
TO TESTIFY VIA REMOTE VIDEO NO
ADS OR ANYONE IN THE ROOM BUT
SHE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
SCENE NINE BOB THE FIGHT OPEN
IT UP FOR FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
I JUST WANTED HIM I THINK
THE AUTHOR AND ALSO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS -- FOR FOR WORKING
TOGETHER COLLABORATIVELY TO
TO BRING YOUR TWO BILLS AND
PROPOSALS TOGETHER -- IN
PARTICULAR APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS IS WILLINGNESS
TO DEPOSIT HIS BILL AND FOLDS
HIS CONCEPTS IN WITH YOURS
JUST FOR THE AVOIDANCE OF
DOUBT THERE ARE CERTAINLY NO
AT POLICY APPREHENSIONS ON
ON OUR PART RELATED TO YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RECESSES AT
TEN TWENTY FIVE ON THEY WERE
VERY SIMILAR BILLS AIMING TO
ACHIEVE SIMILAR GOALS AND TO US
WE ASK OTHERS TO WORK TOGETHER
IN THE INTEREST OF LIMITED
CAPACITY THIS LEGISLATIVE
SESSION SO APPRECIATE THAT
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO LET BE FLEXIBLE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AS WELL AND
WITH THAT QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
HI ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA WHAT
IT REALLY TO CARE AND THANKING
THE -- OPTED FOR BRING BILL
FOR FIVE THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD -- I
THINK IT'S A VERY COMMON SENSE
-- APPROACH TO BOTH ENCOURAGE
AND SUPPORT CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE AND WITH THAT
I'D LIKE TO ASK THE AUTHORED
TO PLEASE BE ADDED AS COOPER
THANK MISTER PATTERSON THANK
YOU JUST WHAT ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF THE CHAIR IN APPRECIATION
OF THE WORKING TOGETHER BETWEEN
-- SOMEONE RIVAS AND -- AND
YOUR BILL BUT BOTH GOOD IDEAS
-- CUT A LOT OF SAME TERRITORY
PRECIADO A COMMITMENT TO WORK
TOGETHER AND AND MOVE FORWARD
ON THAT -- -- WITH THAT --
DOES THIS NEED A MOTION AND
A SECOND YES I WOULD LIKE
TO MOTION ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU I SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON AND
A SECOND TO BUY AT ASSEMBLY
NUMBER BURKE -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
I WANT JUST RECOGNIZE ALSO --
CHAIRED RIVAS IS LEADERSHIP
ON THE ISSUE WE ARE WORKING
HAND IN GLOVE ON THE MATTER
WE ARE MEETING WITH THEM THE
SPONSORS OF HIS BILL THE AG
COUNCIL WHICH I BELIEVE OUT WE
WILL BE ABLE TO INTEGRATE THEM
NINETY NINE POINT NINE PERCENT
OF THE CONCEPTS THAT WERE IN
THAT BILL -- THEIR GOAL WAS
TO ENSURE THAT YOU KNOW FIFTY
PERCENT OF PURCHASING A TOOK
PLACE IN THE UNITED STATES
AND OUR GOAL IS TO ENSURE THAT
THE CALIFORNIA GOALS FIRST
-- SO THAT WE CAN SUPPORT --
CALIFORNIA FARMERS FARM WORKERS
THAT PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT
AS WELL AS ENSURE THAT -- WE'RE
MEETING ALL OF THE REGULATORY
STANDARDS THAT WE AS LAWMAKERS
PASS HERE -- AND IMPOSE ON
INDUSTRIES LIKE AGRICULTURE
SO -- I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
I WOULD TO THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR BRINGING THIS MATTER FOR
THANK YOU I SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE
PETRIE-NORRIS HI PETRIE-NORRIS
I PATTERSON PERCENT HI BURKE
BURKE I GRADE LACKING MEDINA
MEDINA I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
I AB FIVE ZERO THAT BILL IS
OUT AND WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
IF AND FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON
I THINK YOU LET'S SEE ADVISED
HER PATTERSON OUT YOUR UP
NEXT WHENEVER YOU ARE READY
THANK YOU CHAIR AND AND MEMBERS
UP HERE TO PRESENT AB EIGHT
EIGHT FOUR THIS IS A BILL
THAT WILL CHANGE THE EXISTING
REQUIREMENT THAT LARGE STATE
AGENCIES MERELY CONSIDER
CONDUCTING INTERNAL AUDITS
AND INSTEAD MAKE THESE AUDITS
MANDATORY IT WOULD ALSO
ELIMINATE THE ABILITY FOR
AGENCIES TO KEEP THESE AUDITS
SECRET UNDER CURRENT LAW MANY
STATE AGENCIES ARE REQUIRED
TO CONSIDER ESTABLISHING AN
ONGOING AUDIT FUNCTION HOWEVER
ONLY HALF OF THE AGENCIES THAT
MEET THIS REQUIREMENT HAVE DONE
SO THIS LEAVES NEARLY FORTY
AGENCIES WHICH CONTROL MORE
THAN TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS IN
SPENDING WITHOUT ANY ONGOING
INTERNAL AUDIT FUNCTION FOR
THE AGENCIES THAT DO CONDUCT
AUDITS MOST KEEP THOSE REPORTS
ENTIRELY HIDDEN FROM THE PUBLIC
REQUIRING ONGOING AUDITS WILL
IMPROVE THE INTEGRITY AND THE
EFFICIENCY OF STATE GOVERNMENT
IT WILL ENSURE THAT TAXPAYER
DOLLARS ARE USED EFFICIENTLY
AND EFFECTIVELY AND THAT THE
PUBLIC CAN HACK HAVE ACCESS
TO THE CONTENTS AND THE
CONCLUSIONS OF OF THE AUDITS
SO BY MAKING THESE AUDITS
OPEN AND TRANSPARENT WE WILL
PREVENT AGENCIES FROM HIDING
MAJOR ISSUES WHICH HAS BEEN
UNFORTUNATELY THE PRACTICE M.
THE BILL INTENDS TO TRY TO
CHANGE THAT -- THIS BILL
HAS NO OPPOSITION IT HAS --
A SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION BY
THE CHAIR WHICH I APPRECIATE
SO I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
IBOOK THANK YOU UNDERSTAND
IF NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
JOINING US TODAY JUST NOT
OKAY MODERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE MAIN LINE
FOR ANY SUPPORTING TESTIMONY
AND LATER ON IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME AGAIN
SUPPORT FOR AB EIGHT EIGHT
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AND IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NONE
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY VIA
REMOTE VIDEO I SEE NONE ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT C.
NINE A MODERATOR I CAN
OPEN UP THE MAIN LINE FOR
ANY OPPOSITION TESTIMONY
AND NOW KERN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO IN ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION AB EIGHT EIGHT FOUR
YOU CAN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO FOR IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NONE
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION BY REMOTE VIDEO
SCENE NINE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION SEEING NINE AT
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE THE MOVE THE
BILL THANK YOU HOWEVER MOTION
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA
SECOND FROM FILAMENT BERMAN
THREE GUYS FIVE I'LL JUST SAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR AT FOCUS
ON ENHANCING OVERSIGHT AND
IMPROVING TRANSPARENCY IN OUR
OUR GOVERNMENT AGENCIES AND
AND TAX DEPARTMENTS I THINK
IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND
CERTAINLY A PRIORITY THAT WE
SHARE SEPARATE G.
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLASS I'D
APPRECIATE IT AND -- A TO
THE CHAIR AS WELL THANK YOU
FOR THE HELP IN THIS AND AND
THE ENCOURAGEMENT -- AND I
APPRECIATE THAT MOTION THE
SECOND ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
PETRIE-NORRIS HI PETRIE-NORRIS
I PATTERSON KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT IT FOR A MINUTE
PATTERSON HI BURKE
BURKE I GREAT
LACKING MEDINA
MEDINA I RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I AT FIVE L.
ADD THAT BILL IS OUT AND WE
WILL LEAVE THAT ROLE OPEN
FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON NEXT
ON OUR AGENDA IS AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY FIVE -- BY MR BONTA
I BELIEVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BURKE WILL BE PRESENTING ON
BEHALF ASSEMBLY MEMBER NUMBER
BONTA WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS I'M PRESENTING AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROB BONTA AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE IS A BILL
TO FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE ARE
CRYING THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
TO PURCHASE LOWER CARBON IT
CONCRETE IT WILL BUILD ON
THE BUY CLEAN CALIFORNIA ACT
OF TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
CONCRETE IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
CONSTRUCTION MATERIAL HOWEVER
THE PROCESS USED TO MAKE
CONCRETE AND IT'S BINDING
MATERIALS CEMENT IS EXTREMELY
ENERGY INTENSIVE AND PRODUCES
A LARGE AMOUNT OF GREENHOUSE
GASES AND LOCAL AIR POLLUTION
CEMENT PRODUCTION IN CONCRETE
USE IS EXPECTED TO GROW BY
AS MUCH AS FORTY PERCENT IN
CALIFORNIA BY TWENTY TWENTY
WE MUST TACKLE THE EMISSIONS
FROM THE INDUSTRY BEFORE
IT GETS EVEN WORSE RIGHT
NOW MORE THAN SEVEN PERCENT
OF GLOBAL GREENHOUSE GASES
ARE RESULT OF CEMENT AND
CONCRETE PRODUCTION ALONE
BUT ADVANCES IN TECHNOLOGY
HAVE ALLOWED THE INDUSTRY TO
PRODUCE LOWER CARBON CONCRETE
MIXTURES THAT MEET THE SAME
PERFORMANCE STANDARDS BUT
WITH REDUCE GHGS AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY FIVE WILL BUILD ON
RESEARCH CONDUCTED BY CALTRANS
AND OTHERS ESTABLISH A THREE
YEAR RUN WAY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO SET A STANDARD
FOR LOW CARBON CONCRETE AND
THEN PURCHASE GREENER CONCRETE
CALIFORNIA SPENDS ROUGHLY TEN
BILLION PER YEAR ON PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY FIVE WILL FURTHER ALIGN
CALIFORNIANS SPENDING WITH
ITS ENVIRONMENTAL VALUES AND
CLIMATE GOALS WITH ME TODAY
IS ALEX JACKSON -- WITH THE
NATURE RESOURCES DEFENSE FUND
ON THE PHONE AND HER BURDEN
REGIONAL VICE PRESIDENT AND
GENERAL MANAGER OF U.
S. CONCRETE INC I THINK YOUR
MODERATOR PLEASE CAN YOU OPEN
AT THE LINE FOR ALEX JACKSON
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
ALEX JACKSON ON BEHALF OF AN
RTC BUT PLEASED TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
FIVE TODAY WE DON'T HEAR A LOT
ABOUT CONCRETE WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE THAT WE
SET ASIDE FROM WATER CONCRETE
IS THE MOST WIDELY CONSIDERED
MATERIAL ON HER KEYCHAIN
READING INTO MEANT AS SARCASM
ABOUT THE -- IT CONTRIBUTES
ABOUT EIGHTY PERCENT OF
GLOBAL CO TWO EMISSIONS BY
MEANS OF THE GLOBAL CEMENT
INDUSTRY WERE A COUNTRY IT
WOULD BE THE THIRD LARGEST
INTERNET FALLS BEHIND ONLY
CHINA AND THE UNITED STATES
TO MAKE SURE CALIFORNIA'S
EMISSIONS OF SMALLER THE
GREENHOUSE GASES OF COURSE
KNOW NO BORDERS CALIFORNIA
WILL REMAIN VULNERABLE
ESCALATING CLIMATE IMPACTS
FROM SEA LEVEL RISE WILDFIRE'S
ABSENCE SCALABLE SOLUTIONS
TO REDUCE CONCRETE'S CARBON
FOOTPRINT THANKFULLY YOU KNOW
WHERE TO START MOST CONCRETE
AS COACHES BY GOVERNMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA CAN PULL FORWARD
LOW CARBON TECHNOLOGIES AND
BEST PRACTICES ACROSS THE
CEMENT CONCRETE SUPPLY CHAIN BY
LEVERAGING MASSIVE PURCHASING
POWER TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO BUY
CLEAN CALIFORNIA ACT SET OUT
TO DO JUST THAT BY CREATING
A FRAMEWORK TO ACCOUNT FOR
THE BY ELECTIONS AND BUILDING
MATERIALS INSTEAD OF THE REDUCE
THE CLIMATE IMPACT CONCRETE
WAS INITIALLY EXCLUDED BUT
NOW IT COUNTY TOOLS SUCH
AS ENVIRONMENTAL PRODUCT
DECLARATIONS ARE WIDELY IN
USE LOWER CARBON BUDGETS MEANT
GAINING ACCEPTANCE LEAVING
CALIFORNIA CITY THE CAMPUSES
UPDATED THE SPECIFICATIONS
TO ALLOW CONCRETE PRODUCER
OPTIMIZED FOR PERFORMANCE IN
A CHEAP SIGNIFICANT EMISSIONS
AND COSTS IT THE BILL ON THE
PROGRESS OF AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
FIVE INITIATE THE SCHEDULE
TO CORPORATE CONCRETE INTO BY
QUICK CHOIRS CONCRETE PRODUCERS
SPENDING ON THE STATE PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECTS TO DISCLOSE
THE CARBON FOOTPRINT OF THE
CHECKS TO CREATE A FORMER
DEFENSE TO DRIVE CLIMATE
COMPETITION FOR THE CLEANEST
PRODUCTS IN OVERTIME AND SET
THE MINIMUM STANDARDS TO ALIGN
TO CALIFORNIA'S INFRASTRUCTURE
SPENDING WITH OUR CLINICAL
BYFLEET GEVA MENTOR ON THE
GLOBAL CALIFORNIA HAD LITTLE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHAPE THOSE
OUTCOMES LEAD BY EXAMPLE
RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT I THOUGHT
THANK YOU OUR MODERATOR
I CAN NOW PLEASE CONNECT
US WITH A HER BURDENS
SHE
HELLO AND THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME TODAY -- TWENTY THIRD
BURDENS WITH US CONCRETE --
YOU WITH CONCRETE AS A BEEN
IN THE FOREFRONT OF THE OF
THE MISSION TO LOWER CARBON
IMPACTS OF THE CONCRETE -- IN
ALL OF IT AND ALL THE DIFFERENT
PRODUCT LINES -- WE UNDERSTAND
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WITH THE
BIKE REACT FIRST CAME OUT
IN CONCRETE WITH THE MINUTE
THAT THE TECHNOLOGY DIDN'T
EXIST FOR ALL PRODUCERS HAVE
BPD IS AND AND AND THAT WOULD
SEEM LIKE A HURDLE BUT THE
REPORTING IN -- IN TRANSPARENCY
OF THE PDS ENVIRONMENTAL
PRODUCT DECLARATIONS OF
BECOME MUCH MORE WIDELY USED
TODAY IN NORTHERN CAL IN
NORTH AMERICA THERE THIRTY
TWO THOUSAND ENVIRONMENTAL
PRODUCT DECLARATIONS FOR
CONCRETE PRODUCTS WE BELIEVE
THE TECHNOLOGY IS WIDELY --
ACCEPTABLE CALLED LEVEL THE
PRODUCER SMALL AND LARGE
AND WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT
THAT TRANSPARENCY CAN CREATE
THE FOOT BUT THE FOUNDATION
OF HELPING DESIGNERS AND
SPECIFIERS METER CARBON
GOALS THEIR PROJECT AND ALSO
ALLOW FOR BETTER TRANSPARENCY
INTO THOSE EMBODIED CARBON
IMPACT IN OUR BOOK BARN --
BY ALLOWING UP WE WAS WE
VERY MUCH SUPPORT AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY FIVE IN ITS MISSION TO
ALLOW FOR A PERFORMANCE BASED
SPECIFICATIONS AS WELL --
ALLOWING -- PRODUCERS AND --
SPECIFIERS WORK TOGETHER TO
DRIVE DOWN THE CARBON IMPACT
IN A GIVEN PROJECT -- THROUGH
OPTIMIZATION OF MIXES AND ALSO
THAT THE CAN HAVE A SECONDARY
PART TO THE FACT THAT LOWERING
OVERALL PROJECT COSTS AND THEN
UP AFFECTING THE TAXPAYERS
AND IMPACT ON TAXPAYERS FOR
A STATE AND LOCAL PROJECTS
SO WE APPRECIATE THAT TIME
TO TALK AND -- WE JUST WOULD
PROBABLY YOU WOULD SUPPORT
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU L. I.
MODERATOR CAN YOU NOW PLEASE
OPEN UP THE MAIN LINE FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTING TESTIMONY
IN LAYS GERMAN IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AGAIN ONE ZERO
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
AT THIS TIME IT DOES LOOK LIKE
THEY'RE ABOUT FOUR IN THE QUEUE
WE'LL START WITH NUMBER
FIFTY NINE -- PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI MY NAME IS KATHY DRIVEN I
AM WITH THREE FIFTY BAY AREA
ACTIONS HELPED ME FIFTEEN
SILICON VALLEY WE'RE CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY FIVE EIGHT THANK YOU
THE NEXT WILL BE NUMBER
SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
NUMBER IS THE KEY TO
KARATE WITH ENERGY C.
BUT I'M CALLING TO REGISTER
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF COALITION
FOR CLEAN AIR SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA COMPANY LEAGUE
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND
CARBON ONE EIGHTY THANKS MUCH
NEXT WE'LL GO TO NUMBER
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
BACKSTOPS OLIGOMERIC INSTITUTE
OF STEEL CONSTRUCTION THAT
REPRESENTING THE ONLY MAJOR
STRUCTURAL MATERIAL CURRENTLY
ADDRESSED BY THE ACT WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY FIVE IN ORDER TO ENHANCE
AND BRING FAIRNESS TO THE ACT
X. IS GONNA BE NUMBER
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
CHRISTINE STEVENS ON
BEHALF OF THREE FIFTY BAY
AREA IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE
THE NEXT WILL HAVE NUMBER
SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE CITY AND YOU WONDER
WHAT THE TO CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
FIVE ON BEHALF OF EACH USE
TWENTY SIX HUNDRED BUSINESS
MEMBER CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MADAM CHAIR THANK
YOU IS THERE ANYONE WISHING
TO TESTIFY VIA REMOTE VIDEO
STATION SEEN NONE SIR ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM WHICH
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT SEEN
NINE UP MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
NOW IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION
OF AB THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AGAIN OPPOSITION
AT THE TIME THERE ARE NONE
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
MENTOR IS THERE ANYONE WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
VIA REMOTE VIDEO STATION
SEEN NONE FOR ANYONE WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
IN THE HEARING ROOM SEEING
THAT NONE I WILL OPEN IT UP
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE THE BILL
AND WE HAVE A MOTION AND
WE HAVE A SECOND THE MOTION
MR MEDINA THE SECOND FOR MR
RODRIGUEZ ALL RIGHT AND WITH
THAT UP WITH THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BURKE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLICK ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BUNCH I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST TONIGHT ABOUT THANK YOU
AS SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
NATURAL RESOURCES PETRIE-NORRIS
HI PETRIE-NORRIS I PATTERSON
BURKE HI BURKE HI GREAT BLACKIE
MEDINA MEDINA I RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I AT FOUR ZERO THAT
BELL IS OUT AND WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON
AND THAT NEXT UP IS THIRTEEN
SIXTY NINE ALSO BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA BEING PRESENTED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS I'M PRESENTING
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROB
BONTA A COMPLIMENTARY MEASURE
TO AB THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE IS ALSO A
BILL TO AFFECT CARBON EMISSION
REDUCTIONS FROM BUILDINGS
BY REQUIRING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PURCHASED LOWER
CARBON BUILDING MATERIALS CAR
LOWER CARBON BUILDING TEARS
APPROXIMATELY FORTY PERCENT
OF ALL GLOBAL CARBON EMISSIONS
ARISE FROM THE MANUFACTURING
TRANSPORTATION INSTALLATION
MAINTENANCE AND DISPOSAL OF
BUILDING MATERIALS AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY NINE WILL BUILD ON THE
BUY CLEAN CALIFORNIA ACTED
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN BY
AND ADDING INTERIOR PRODUCTS
WHERE THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT
OPPORTUNITY FOR CARBON
REDUCTION MOSTLY IMPORTANTLY
OR CRY THE STATE DEPARTMENT
OF GENERAL SERVICE TO ADD ANY
OTHER MAJOR STRUCTURAL MATERIAL
TO THE BY CLEAN PROGRAM
WHEN THERE'S SUFFICIENT DATA
AVAILABLE TO DO SO THIS BILL
WILL FURTHER LINE CALIFORNIA
IS ROUGHLY TEN BILLION ANNUAL
PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE SPENDING
WITH ITS ENVIRONMENTAL VALUES
AND CLIMATE GOALS JOIN ME TO
WRITE TESTIMONY THIS AFTERNOON
IS DANIEL BUT FOR VERY SENIOR
OF A CLUTCH SO HURRY TO HANDLE
OF THE ORACLE CALIFORNIA
AND EVEN ANY ON BEHALF OF
INTERFACE INC AND AT WITH THE
MODERATOR NOW PLEASE CONNECT
US WITH ADS DANIEL GARAGE
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
DANIEL BROAD ON BEHALF SUBJECT
BUT CALIFORNIA AND I'M MORE
THAN FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
MEMBERS AND SUPPORTERS
STATEWIDE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE WHICH WOULD
EXPAND BY CLAIM CALIFORNIA
ACT AND COMMON SENSE AND
IMPORTANT WAYS CALIFORNIA
SHOULD BE SPENDING AND PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE DOLLARS IN
A MANNER THAT IS CONSISTENT
WITH ITS NECESSARILY AMBITIOUS
CLIMATE GOALS THAT ENDS THEY'RE
QUICK CALIFORNIA WITH A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THE BY CLICKING
CALIFORNIA ACT WAS SIGNED
IN JULY NEARLY SITES YEARS
AGO THEN BETA BLOCK REQUIRED
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES TO ESTABLISH A MAXIMUM
GLOBAL WARMING POTENTIAL
FOR A MOMENT LAST OF COMMON
CONSTRUCTION MATERIALS BUT
THE STATE PREPARES FOR PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECTS AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY NINE FAILED ON THE BY
CONSTRAINED MARC AND EXPAND
THE BY QUEEN CALIFORNIA ACT BY
ADDING A SMALL SET UP INTERIOR
PRODUCTS WHETHER IT'S VERY HIGH
POTENTIAL FOR CARBON REDUCTION
IN PAVE THE WAY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
TO ADD ELIGIBLE MATERIAL AS
DATA BECOMES AVAILABLE BY PLANE
BUT ALWAYS INTENDED TO INCLUDE
MORE PRODUCT MERGING TOLD ARE
MAKING GATHERING THAT DATA THE
NECESSARY DATA EASIER FOR BOTH
MANUFACTURERS AND THE STATE
THAT THIS BILL IS A SENSIBLE
NEXT STEP IN ADDRESSING CARBON
EMISSIONS AND CALIFORNIA'S
SUPPLY CHAIN BUT BUILT LOGICAL
AND TIMELY IS THAT LOGICAL AND
TIMELY STEP TOWARD SLOWING THE
CLIMATE CRISIS AND FOR THAT
REASON SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
NINE AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR EYES OUT THANK YOU YOU
MISTER BROD AND DIVE WITH THE
MODERATOR NOW PLEASE CONNECT
US WITH THAT MS MINETTI
HI I'M GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
ENGINE READY HERE ON BEHALF
OF INTERSTATE INCORPORATED A
WORLDWIDE COMMERCIAL FLOORING
MANUFACTURER IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE --
OUR INTEREST STARTED IN THIS
ISSUE WHEN OUR CLIENT --
WHO ARE LARGE BUSINESSES AND
UNIVERSITIES IN CALIFORNIA --
BEGAN USING CARBON FOOT PRINT
I DO WAY TO SCREEN PURCHASES
AND HIT THEIR CARBON REDUCTION
COMMITMENT ARE WE ALREADY KNOW
THERE IS CARBON INVOLVED IN
CONSTRUCTION MATERIALS WHICH IS
WHAT THE FIRST BY CLEAN ACTED
-- BUT WE'VE OFTEN OVERLOOKED
EMBODIED CARBON IT IS SEATED
WITH ALL INTERIOR PRODUCT --
I OUR FRIEND IN THE CEMENT
INDUSTRY HAD MENTIONED IN A
PREVIOUS TESTIMONY THERE ARE --
THERE'S AN EXPLORATION IN THE
NUMBER AND AVAILABILITY ETT VAL
ACROSS MANY PRODUCT CATEGORIES
ALL COMPLETELY VOLUNTARY MANY
FACTORS LIKE I HAVE FOUND THAT
ENVIRONMENTAL TRANSPARENCY
YIELD MARKET BENEFITS SUCH
AS ACHIEVING GREEN PRODUCT
CERTIFICATION BOTH OF THE GREEN
BUILDING MOVEMENT HAS BEEN
AND CONTINUES TO BE DEEPLY
INFLUENCED BY MARKET DEMAND
-- WEST AT WITH BY CLEAN FROM
FIVE YEARS AGO BEING LIMITED TO
HEAVY CONSTRUCTION MATERIALS WE
THINK THIS IS THE NEXT LOGICAL
STEP TO EXPAND TO ENSURE
YOUR PRODUCT THAT MAKE UP A
SIGNIFICANT PERCENTAGE OF THE
BUILDING AND BODY CARBON TOTAL
-- WE BELIEVE THAT WITH NEW
RESOURCES LIKE THE EASY THREE
TO ALL THAT MAKE D.
P. PT DPT VISIT HIGH AND WIDELY
AVAILABLE -- THIS IS GOING TO
HELP THE STATE EMPLOYMENT AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE AS WE LEARN
MORE ABOUT FUTURE CATEGORY
THAN INDUSTRY INNOVATION THIS
BILL WILL ALSO OPERATE BGS TO
ADD MORE ELIGIBLE MATERIALS
WHEN SUFFICIENT DATA IS
AVAILABLE AND INDUSTRY BATES
FINE DARK BABYLISS THIS IS A
WIN WIN FOR BOTH MANUFACTURED
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
BY HELPING SUPPLIERS WITH
BAYERN MENTALLY RESPONSIBLE
PRODUCT BECOME EASIER TO
SELECT AND DO BUSINESS WITH
THE STATE AND ALSO HELP THE
STATE REDUCE THE CARBON IMPACT
JUST FROM PURCHASING WITHOUT
ANY CAPITAL INVESTMENT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE AND WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A BI THIRTEEN SIXTY
NINE THANK YOU IS NOT A AND
WITH THE MODERATOR NOW PLEASE
OPEN UP THE MAIN LINE FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTING TESTIMONY
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
SECOND ONE ZERO FOUR SUPPORT
AND AT THE MOMENT WE DO
HAVE ABOUT TWO IN THE QUEUE
THANK YOU I WILL START
WITH NUMBER SIX OR NUMBER
SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MAKE YOU CRY AGAIN WITH ENERGY
YOU SEE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT TO BE NUMBER
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO AGAIN MAX BUT FELLOW WITH
THE AMERICAN INSTITUTE OF STEEL
CONSTRUCTION REPRESENTING THE
ONLY MAJOR STRUCTURAL MATERIAL
CURRENTLY ADDRESSED BY THE BIKE
LANE CALIFORNIA ACT WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY NINE IN ORDER TO ENHANCE
AND BRING FAIRNESS TO THE ACT
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
THIS TIME THERE ARE NO FURTHER
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY VIA
REMOTE VIDEO STATION C.
NINE IS THERE ANYONE IN
HEARING ROOM SHE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT SEEN NINE FIVE
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
NOW OPEN THE MAIN LINE FOR
ANY OPPOSITION TESTIMONY
AFTER IN OPPOSITION AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AGAIN ALL OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NONE
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
MANAGER IS THERE ANYONE WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION FIVE
REMOTE VIDEO SEEN NONE ANYONE
IN THE ROOM WERE SEEN TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION SCENE
NINE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE SOME OF THE
BILL THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION
FOR MISTER MEDINA A SECOND FOR
MR RODRIGUEZ ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BURKE WOULD YOU LIKE TO PUT
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROB BONTA I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AND I ABOUT THANK
YOU HEALTH SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
PETRIE-NORRIS HI PETRIE-NORRIS
HI PATTERSON BURKE BURKE HI
GREG LACKEY MEDINA MEDINA
I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
THANK YOU ARE RIGHT UP WITH
THAT WE WILL OUT MOVED TO
ADOPT THE COMMITTEE ROLES FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO LEGISLATIVE SESSION I DO
I HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
FOR THE COMMITTEE GIRLS
IT'S OBVIOUS BY -- IS BURKE
SECONDED BY MR MEDINA SECRETARY
CAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THIS
IS FOR COMMITTEE ADOPTION OF
COMMITTEE ROLES PETRIE-NORRIS
HI PETRIE-NORRIS I PATTERSON
BURKE BURKE I GREAT BLACKIE
MEDINA MEDINA I RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I YOU AND AT THIS
POINT I WOULD LIKE TO MOVE
TO OUR PROPOSED CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR TODAY WHICH
INCLUDES FILE ITEM TO AB THREE
FORTY THREE OUR BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FONG WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR MOVED BY WITH THE
MOTION OF AYE MR RODRIGUEZ
AND A SECOND FROM THIS BURKE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO COMMITTEE ON THE JUDICIARY
PETRIE-NORRIS HI PETRIE-NORRIS
HI PATTERSON BURKE BURKE I
GREAT LACKEY MEDINA MEDINA
I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
AND WE'VE GOT ONE MORE AT
BILLS THAT WE NEED TO YOU TO
CONSIDER I EIGHT B.
FORTY SIX BY THE MEMBER RIVAS
I HOPE SHE PRESENTED BEFORE WE
HAD ESTABLISHED A QUORUM -- DID
WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND ON
THAT NETWORK CAPS OF WE NEED
ARE AT WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
THIS RODRIGUEZ SECOND FROM MR
MEDINA SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
COMMITTEE ON HUMAN RESOURCES
PETRIE-NORRIS HI PETRIE-NORRIS
I PATTERSON BURKE BURKE I
GREAT BLACKIE MEDINA MEDINA
I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I ALL
RIGHT I HAVE FOUR OF THAT BILL
IS OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT AT
THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHERS TO
ADD ON ON THAT DOES IT JOURNAL
ARE ITEMS AND WE WILL AT GO
AHEAD AND LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR FIVE MINUTES -- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO JOIN US AND OUT ON
DID YOU THEN
THE PROBLEM THE
PROBLEM WITH THAT
THANK YOU
YEAH YOU
RIGHT AS A NEW YES THERE ARE
A COUPLE OF ITEMS THAT ARE ON
CALL AT DETECTOR IF YOU AND
REVIEW THOSE ITEMS AND CALL
THE ROLL YES WE CAN START
WITH THE CONSENT AB THREE FOUR
THREE THAT IS A DO PASSED TO
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ENSURE DISH PATTERSON PATTERSON
I GREAT GRAY I THEN WE CAN
MOVE ON TO AB FORTY SIX BY
THREE OF US THAT IS A D.
PASSER FOR TO COMMITTEE
ON HUMAN RESOURCES
PATTERSON ABSTAINED
GREAT A GREAT GREAT I
WE WILL MOVE ON TO
AB SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT
TWO BY EDUARDO GARCIA
GREAT FIVE GREAT I
NEXT IS AB EIGHT EIGHT FOUR
PATTERSON GREAT GREAT I
A. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE
BY BONTA GREAT RATE I
PATTERSON PATTERSON NOT VOTING
NEXT IS AB THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE
AGAIN BY BONTA GREAT ALL RIGHT
GREAT I PATTERSON NOT LOADING
I DON'T
THEY ONLY
OUR GOODNESS SORRY I'VE BEEN
RUNNING INTO LOCAL KIND OF
WHAT OKAY ALL RIGHT N.
DOT MADAM SECRETARY YOU CAN
GO AHEAD AND LASSEN ABSENT
MEMBERS TO ADD ON CONSENT
CALENDAR AB THREE FOUR
THREE FONG LACKEY LACKEY I
AB FORTY SIX LOWER
RIVER BLACKIE BLACKIE I
A. B. SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT
EDUARDO GARCIA LACKEY LACKEY I
AB EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT
FOUR PATTERSON LACKEY
OKAY I'M BLACKIE I
A. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE
BONTA BLACKIE NO MACHENAUD
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE LACKEY
PORTLAND OKAY BLACK EMAIL
WITH THAT AT TODAY'S COMMITTEE
BUSINESS IS CONCLUDED AND I I
HEREBY ADJOURNED THE HEARING
SORRY FOR THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT